I've always been curious how much do you
have to cut out of cold ones everything
you're generally Cooks considering like
because you want you want the truth yeah
I want to I want the truth the hand meme
you know what I meant though you knew
what I meant
I'm just sorry just I feel bad for the
you know the guy who made that show has
been reduced to that
24 seasons working hard for children
to answer your question yeah a lot no uh
our typical recording minimum right is
three and a half hours Jesus
that makes a 15 minute video [__]
hell because it's it's hard because it's
just like whole sections that you're
like that wasn't funny just get rid of
it no no
sometimes but not really you just like
chocolate
yeah patreon Cuts like an hour long
patreon gets like massive extended Cuts
right right yeah because we actually you
ever really have to cut something out of
our podcast uh that's probably gonna be
one of them where you show your ass
that's uh
when you're drinking on a podcast you
get really drunk
you get sidetracked and you start
talking about something else and then
you're you're on a political debate for
now talking about like why Obama was a
better president political debates do
you have not actually
oh yeah you get onto a topic and you're
drunk with the boys and you're talking
like you're talking trash this already
has so many [__] tangents could you
imagine if we were shit-faced every
episode well you gotta find out tonight
oh my God that's why I said prepare your
liver because we've cut stuff though
we've cut like segments before but we
cut so so much we you gotta sometimes if
we if we talk about politics for some
reason I don't know how we get on it I
feel like that always be cut yeah
because it was just like you you watch
it like we're just [__] dumb yeah
yeah
I I have a thing where it's like
a lot of time people want me to have an
opinion on something and I think it's
okay to say like I I don't know enough
to feel like my opinion that I should
form an opinion I'm gonna get annoyed
because they're like why don't you know
yeah yeah exactly and it's like yeah but
what they're really saying is you should
be part of what I think yeah yeah rather
than me being like you know I want to
educate myself sure like sure it's funny
that they've they one cold ones of all
shows to get more political I just you
know you can do that with anything
everything is awesome yeah I don't know
how he feels about the current like
housing crisis
a simple answer bad
yeah but when you sit down with the boys
and you're drinking you just start
talking about stuff and then you look
back in the footage Lane you're like
that's not interesting we're talking
about [__] how we can poison kids and
get away with it like like that's a
premium that sounds like premium
one prime example uh we did a podcast uh
with someone and there was someone else
on the show and we just [__] walked
offset for now and just start talking
off screen and we're like oh [__] we got
a podcast Circle who's this drunk
well like let's take a 10 minute piss
break you know go grab a water and then
we'll continue and then no one tell you
I think people were trying but like let
me cook
oh yeah it's pretty hard to get us back
on track once we're at that point and we
we don't [__] answered any Authority
I've had two beers
yeah there's definitely stuff where as
well as when you're drunk and you look
back at me like oh I can't believe I
said that's so embarrassing I'm too
young yeah we obviously send the footage
to people as well to look at and they go
oh don't leave that in him obviously
drunk I don't need people knowing about
how like my ex-boyfriend [__] sounded
me with a [__] pen or something
no one said that but okay I was gonna
say what you know is this about stuff
being shoved up your ass when you get
drunk he does it this is yeah
let's begin I need to know the context
of this why is this a thing because
have you seen that patreon
patrons we have I mean you have a lot of
patrons yeah
how many patrons do you guys have a
decent amount you guys have yeah I think
yeah we have a decision not nowhere
yeah yeah yeah you guys just make more
money
we're barely like we're terrible we
don't give a lot to the picture yeah
uh just shy of 11 000.
else just went up or what yeah and you
guys [__] you guys fell off
great someone shoved something up my ass
if you guys if one of you bent over and
someone was putting some in your ass
once an episode you would see a spike I
[__] hope so
when it doesn't change the pages
your patreon and an early fans
I mean it's tasteful
when I spread his cheeks it's done in a
way that is more elegant all right can I
just can I just Chad you were saying
before that it's all my fault
um it started with me originally just
getting my [__] out on camera because
I'm drunk and I'm like I don't do that
when I'm dry I love getting my little
tiny [__] and balls
way back yeah
um so that was like the original like
pitch to patreon six sorry real quickly
was it wasn't like one of the first
times that would ever happen on the
flashlight what I pretend to [__] a
flashlight that was one of the reasons
no no no no no no no no not that not no
not that way before that I mean on
didn't had a basic post the photo on his
Twitter of your [__] just out yeah we
were drunk we were drunk around
McDonald's but I swear that was the
first time
you thought he was
post it but you were like you can post
it and then he did and then it was like
oh he actually posted that he took it I
got my [__] out in the Mac is at like
five o'clock
it's around relax do you I got my [__]
out in the casino McDonald's and he took
a photo of it it's like this funny photo
of me like wearing a really nice
button-up shirt person this is all right
honey [__] and balls hanging out and he
posted it and people loved him like
people love it when I get my [__] out
oh
I suddenly took the wrong message
but obviously
in person I like thought he did yeah I
never seen a lot of day and then I woke
up the next morning hunger I'm like why
is my phone did you ever think man this
is like this could be distasteful to
some people maybe I shouldn't do um you
know how accessible porn is have you
looked at Twitter yeah but like I I know
I've been on Twitter and it's better
complain about seeing my [__] in their
feed they're following the wrong people
that's their fault
like you know I mean I see enough
titties on Instagram and like I don't
even follow any only friends girls yeah
so they've got posted and you're like we
can pay all this
fast forward fast forward fast forward
the cold ones okay I start getting drunk
and getting my [__] out a lot of camera
is like can I start leaving your [__] in
it's kind of funny I'm like yeah all
right you can leave it in there and then
we notice our patreon climbed the second
we started putting more [__] on screen
and then the one time we saw it really
blast we got this um we got this like
tripled overnight we got this um lizard
cam which is like a camera attached to a
big long string along like rope and you
have to like shove it behind your fridge
and stuff to see if there's any Critters
there or anything yeah or down like
drain pipes to see where the clock is
and Max looks at me and this is where
it's at because it wasn't my idea and we
can review the footage Max just like one
time this is how it started this is not
that started and he looks at me goes
Chad can I shove this up your ass
we leave it in patreon the patreon
triples overnight so
come on not true so is there a bunch of
people on your patreon who are
exclusively there because they have some
kind of oh yeah I remember
I remember guy recently when I looked in
the comments there was a guy who was
just cataloging every because it was
summer time stamping yeah but someone
new had subscribed he was like where's
Chad's car clay that's what I'm here a
guy replied to that yes literally with
like a time a bunch of time stamps of
every piece of old content being like
this video this this uh patreon uh
podcast at the two hours and 14 seconds
Mark gets his dick out for like a second
in the corner uh blah blah just like
every single possible thing and he was
like replying to it so there's a good
chunk of people who are just there well
that's the only time we see like a
noticeable jump in the patreon is when
there's a point in the video where I get
my [__] out for something we have to
blur I'll say go to page and then it
goes up anyway
you guys are lying if you say you've
never been drunk with the boys and one
guy says I'd be so funny she [__]
like like stripped your like balls or
your kids
we go to the Onsen we always see each
other's figs wait wait Joey what I've
done it
must be a nosy thing
okay Joey we will have been friends for
how many years and this is just
I I've uh I've got my [__] out in front
of the boys before yeah
then you stand out you dick out and you
put the big black box over it that says
the trash taste like my favorites
yeah it was really funny to see you leak
uh Ludwig's balls
that was like an actual accident
just being like the the child I was
drunk when he messaged me yeah the chat
look was so funny you want me to blow
your balls yes
I have an Apple Watch
I don't see the previous messages before
that yeah Max gonna try it how bad is it
with me reading messages about oh he
can't read he just can't read
he's just illiterate I messaged Ludwig I
messaged Ludwig in the morning like so
by the way what happened is that uh
Ludwig's balls were leaked on our
patreon said to them yes so you get
Ludwig's balls too nice balls
I sent him a message in the morning and
I was like oh hey Ludwig um here's the
patreon cut of your episode like just
review it tell us you want anything cut
your balls are still in it because
because in the recording he said yeah
you guys can leave my balls and it's
fine like while he was drunk obviously
and I said if you want us to blow your
balls just let me know
weird and then
I'm drunk that's the day in the cold one
yeah and I'm drunk that night the night
we're meant to be posting at like the
final like three hour Crunch and I just
get this yes LOL and I'm like oh it's
what it is it's funny yeah
I thought I thought in my head I thought
I said hey is it okay if we leave your
balls
so I thought he was I thought he was
replying to yes you can leave my voice
I didn't read the previous messages
because I even I even like took I even
took a photo of my like Apple watch
messages said yes well like yeah he said
it's okay guys and I sent it to the
editors and I'll and it turns out I
didn't read what I actually said above
I've forgotten what I had sent to be fit
he he took it like a
champagne but he made like he took that
and he ran with it yeah yeah yeah yeah
good on him and he hasn't messaged me
since so I mean I always wonder what was
the what was the conversation when it
happened what was it like oh [__] my bad
mate uh did he message you being like yo
no he never messaged me he just like I
just saw a bunch of videos just started
getting tagged in all these like it
seemed like he did the [__] like
press run with it yeah
yeah he milked it for a video he met a
mogulmail yeah yeah yeah and then I
remember all the streamers as well were
reacting to it so it was less like live
stream fails clips about it stuff like
that and I was like man we did this
[__] I'm sorry about it as well
yeah yeah
I'm stupid